hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the self tuning brain
normalizing brain oscillations with
neurofeedback presented by Thomas Ross
researcher department of fundamental
neurosciences University of Geneva I'm
Alexis Krause of lab routes and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's labyrinth is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
he's join me in welcoming dr. Ross I
will now turn the presentation over to
him ok so today I'm going to talk about
neurofeedback and its relationship to
brain oscillations so their
electrochemical oscillations that record
from the brain menu that you record with
the EEG and M eg and I'm going to
provide also a bigger picture in terms
of the theoretical foundation of
neurofeedback how how neurofeedback and
treatment can be used to a therapy and
what may be the mechanisms underlying
its effects which in fact nothing that
has a very long history almost 50 years
now but there hasn't been much
mechanistic insight into how
how neurofeedback induces its effects in
the brain so I'd like to give a bit of
an overview especially on some basics of
eg and here in this slide we can see
that energy is generated by ionic
channel changes where neurons actually
synchronize in time and space and for
example there's innovation here that
should have shown that there is a change
in your own synchronization with an
increase in amplitude so usually when
the neurons fire independently from each
other there is a small amplitude in the
EEG and when they especially some mates
in time and space then there is an
increase of abotu so this gives rise to
the large signals and you can see we
need to try to click on the slider it
works ok so here we so for example here
we have each neuron independently firing
inside of the listener independently and
activating and therefore the overall
summation of these neurons is smaller
because they independently generated
signals so you can see the fluctuations
here at the bottom are smaller and this
is so called this is referred to as the
synchronization of VG and then
conversely when the neurons fire
together in time there is an increase in
inaptitude that is consonant with the
activation and deactivation of the
neurons and this is actually the
research showing that this is actually
related neuronal spiking you can see
here the local field potential actually
is a local measure of the
electromagnetic activity so it's
essentially what you detect on the on
the eg and Scott level one more one more
study to show that this relationship
holds also intracranial II is nice study
by Hagen's that I'll show that during
different phases of the algorithm is
associated with different levels of
spiking so
left-hand side no spiking occurs it's
the up phase of desolation and then when
there's a bad phase the parlor
repolarizes the membrane potentials in
the neurons and therefore increases by
activity and so forth so basically the
idea is that during different levels of
oscillations of different strengths of
oscillation neurons and train
mercilessly are not within the cortical
and critical areas and this is a
displayed by this slide here that we
take two neurons for example and see
that the orange in the black when they
summit in time then they give rise to
this purple trace which is amplitude
modulated so the amplitude increases
once again when the neurons are
synchronous activity and then we get to
the overall eg signal which is what we
record so just like the previous slides
shown you can see different change
different levels of synchronization and
amplitude in this signal the eg signals
so you have each trace signifies one of
the channels that were recording from
and this this is on two different
domains you can see the amplitude domain
which is basically y-axis and then the
frequency domain which is the space
between the peaks so for example in that
yellow a highlighted region there are
some high operative signals there are
also of low frequency because the peak
the distance between the peaks is large
and conversely there are smaller two
signals like little ripples that are
higher frequency activity where the
distance between the peaks is small so
the frequencies are higher so if we were
to then take this resting state
recording or CG and decompose it along
these two dimensions of amplitude and
frequency and throw away time given an
average of this kind of activity so
essentially asking how much activity how
much synchronization or amplitude there
is in a particular frequency which is
what we call free transform and this is
just a metaphor - just to display that
there's an you can imagine that these
these activities are so scale free that
means
smaller smaller solutions right upon
bigger solutions let's so one metaphor
is like this how you see wait and see
you have a larger larger waves and
smaller waves superpose on top
essentially you can summarize this
activity with this spectrum which is
very transforming this tells you
essentially how much synchronization
there is in each of these frequency
bands and in general we know that the
sort of dominance oscillation in the
brain in sense reports is about the
Alpha frequency to turn 10 Hertz also
there's also slower than electrical
delta theta rhythms to below 10 Hertz
and also be torrential faster and this
is usually quite a consistent finding in
healthy cortex and in healthy brains so
we use this kind of as a reference point
to look at how different signature
activities are in brain disorders so for
example if we take this study by showing
around 2011 with M eg they looked at the
average spectrum for four country
healthy controls and patient groups
across it's a freely
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
depression and we can see that each of
these photos has almost an unique
fingerprint of the overall day they all
demonstrates an increase in low
frequency attitude as well as high
frequency athletes but this is if you
have resolved all the channels together
in fact what's also unique is that the
actual generators of these frequencies
so for example in hatha controls the
most strongest theta generated the one
that generates the most eager attitude
will be in a sort of occipital areas
whereas in obsessive-compulsive disorder
this listener moves to actually mineral
called cortex so there's the difference
also in this translation patterns as
well as their location and this is
specific to this word and one last slide
to show that in fact synchronization
patterns in the brain are can sort of
dictate a lot of behavioral changes and
one of the greatest ones is lots of
questions so when we
apply and it says in aesthetics to the
brain without a proper fall we can see a
clear signature of this of its action in
the functional activity on the
stabilization patterns for example here
I showed you here as this 10 Hertz alpha
band that increases to very very high
levels compared to the waiting States
you see by the red band in the middle so
previously shown that alpha tivity is
dominant rhythm and usually this is in
the back of the head sort of simple
areas here you can see that the frontal
lobe becomes highly active in alpha and
that actually loses leads to loss of
consciousness and the coupling of the
brain from the environment so many
different patterns are involved with
States behavioral States and some can
also be pathological or different from
normal waking States so why is this
important well essentially we can use
this kind of synchronization framework
to perhaps come up with a sort of a
model of why and how and your feedback
works on the brain and essentially one
of the we're proposing is based on
complexity theory which is that you know
there's two extremes of coupling in
found in the physical systems you can
take the one extreme with a low coupling
which would be like a gas which usually
gives rise to a white noise signals when
the animals are not coupled at all or
they just interact with each other
randomly and this is also a source of
calcium noise Leslie on the left hand
the hand of the spectrum and then on the
right hand spectrum you have the high
coupling which you consider in all to a
coupling or in lattice structures like
solids and then we also know that in
living systems this coupling is
intermediate and this is what we call
sort of the critical region between this
one and all other which is so called
criticality theory and lines underlying
theory now they're having some know how
to relate the coupling to
synchronization
essentially there it's almost a sort of
basic relationship that usually with
higher coupling there's highest
realization so there's more there's more
interaction between elements and
therefore they they can exchange
information or activity and therefore
they train each other so just to give an
example of this if you could Tracy
please lose the video now to see how
coupling is related to synchronization
in networks particularly in brain
networks
you
okay so so this is a video by all of
spawns group looking at how connectivity
networks determines network dynamics
civilization so here we can have an
example of a locally connected network
you can see the only clusters are
connected overall okay so with that
video what we saw is that in fact a
civilization can be likely to two
different levels of coupling and usually
high levels of coupling leads to higher
civilization levels and this is a theory
that has been first suggested by Newton
only in the 1998 looking at how
information is transmitted in the brain
and whether the brain is sort of nice
that if not to move distance between
these two extremes of high and low
coupling which leads to highest connect
steep axons as we've seen in the video
where intermediate levels of coupling
so-called small world's connectivity
levels would lead to the most complex
patterns and that's where the brain
operates ignore esting State so for
example we have this example here where
we have very low levels of coupling and
patterns are more Gaussian and then the
other extreme where we have high levels
of happen in here the patterns are
rhythmic just like we see when when
large waves are generated in the brain
for example and then we have a sense
immediate level coupling where the atoms
are more complex and their clusters that
move across time space so they're multi
scale kind of activity that they prefer
as resting state series so why why would
this intermediate state be beneficial or
important for brain processing well one
theory is theory of criticality really
puts forward that this is an
intermediate state between these two
extremes and that being poisoned in the
middle between these two extremes the
brain can then visit in a multi stable
manner many different states
including a low and high coupling levels
but that allows it to be basically
equally of equal distance from these two
extremes in fact probably doing
different tasks the brain needs to visit
different levels of configuration of
both low and high copyin so that gives
you the flexibility to do that for
example here is is enough for power
plots at the bottom that's showing that
for example during attention to touch
versus attention to vision there is a
decrease of alpha which is inhibitory
the motor cortex in the sensory cortex
that's they were concerned with a low
level of alpha so the brain in visits
this region within those cortical
regions so state 1 and then at the same
time we want to inhibit the task of
relevant regions for example individual
areas which are not related to tasks so
there you would have an increase of
coupling which as we know alpha is gates
4 for information processing anything
ethnic the rhythmic oscillation
basically decreases the information
complexity of that region so that gives
the brain flexibility to basically
engage different patterns different
times and in different regions of the
brain so that we would say that this
intermediate opening is is a kind of a
best-of world states from which to
depart from so to go to a clinical
example I want to talk to you a little
bit about the normal development versus
a attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder which is one chemical disorder
wherein your feedback has been applied
to then before we get to the new
feedback aspects I want to just
introduce you that what happens to the
EEG and these frequency spectra during
development and we know that from this
paper here for example that young
children one year olds they have a much
larger spectral power or amplitude in
these lower frequencies below 10 Hertz
ninety-two range and you can see the
peak frequency of this activity is
usually around seven Hertz then as we
mature with time there's some pruning
going on in brain that specializes the
decreases the connectivity between
neurons and therefore this this lower
frequency synchronization is loads
frequency balance decreases overall
absolutely and also increases in
frequency so some of the peak frequency
accelerates to 10 Hertz which is your
dominant alpha rhythm usually so that's
a typical development for healthy brain
and we also know that this is meant to
changes in gray matter volume so I said
probably there's a relationship there in
terms of synaptic pruning where the gray
matter volume decreases with maturation
so you can imagine that the brain is
kind of like a wild forest at the
beginning with all the potential
connections in the brain but then as we
specialized in experience this this
these specializing they become less
connected anymore more refines and
therefore the decreasing the coupling in
the brain and that also decreases the
gray matter volume and this we can see
with correlations people grandmother one
and so with power in frontal cortex as
well as the private cortex and see why
is that interesting well essentially
this relates to potentially some
chemical disorders and we know that
attentional deficit from this slide you
can see that in fact the synchronization
levels or the amplitudes are
consistently higher in in the chemical
groups compared to their normative HMH
groups so starting with children you can
see immediately that although healthy
children display higher synchronization
then then adults they're sort of their
clinical reference group the ADHD
children have even higher ionization in
the Delta Theta bands and then
subsequently also the same thing happens
with adolescence you can see in the
adolescence have a higher power in
and then in Annals the same thing
successfully this increased coupling
probably in the brain
who is connectivity in the brain is
leading to this attentional deficit we
also know that children have lower
attention levels than that get out so
that school system is narrative this is
it during the resting States know what
happens you're in task States
essentially we find the same thing that
joins task when children are needed to
really City probably decreases coupling
to engage attention as you can see
controls they are higher than controls
in both types of ADHD in the occipital
areas where the algorithm is is not
synchronized enough doesn't decrease
enough during tasks and this is also
being replicating adolescence by the
military group showing that so exactly
alpha rhythm still what's decreased
enough during the tenth of states so
what does that mean in terms of our
model essentially it means that probably
the Navy's deep brain is relying on this
more towards the left to the right of
this coupling spectrum when
synchronization levels are higher
generally because of over connectivity
and that is that is leads to the highly
G power patterns of this subtype and
then if they are sort of poised more to
the right step then their full dynamic
range is not exploited so in fact they
only have an enum range more to the
right of the figure than in the middle
being poised in the middle where they
can visit all the necessary states that
are beneficial for information
processing and attention and just a
slide to show that there this causality
to this between civilization patterns
and behavior we can see that with the
stimulants that are the frontline
treatment for ADHD
for example we for stimulants as I
showed you children with ADHD
demonstrated some power increases here
in the middle plots
middle color which is usually which is
then normalized by methylphenidate which
is a strong energy agent that usually
decreases correlation between neurons
that leads to lower circulation and
theta band and that then leads to also
in criminal behavior but there's a
causality there between normalization of
DG and improvement in simple symptoms
and finally to get to the methods on
your feedback well this is one of the
latest studies that showed the causal
relationship between changes in thicker
power and change the nadasdy symptoms
following their feedback so in this
study they used things a bit in your
feedback so they were trying to decrease
the theta beta ratio of the G around mid
line electrodes and to see after 30
sessions of training what would happen
to their symptoms and interestingly they
found that with long-term decreases in
resting state theta there also decreases
in symptoms course so improvement in
energy symptoms that's demonstrated by
by this correlation here so
normalization of theta ability just like
with methylphenidate leads to an
improvement in maybe g symptoms and then
conversely and interestingly if we take
the theta power baseline which should be
sort of a buyer for how normal that
individual lies from the comparative
normative group it shows that the higher
the theta is then more quickly that
protocol was for that for that person
which also nesting it may be some some
children that did not demonstrate this
by more than that protocol would not be
beneficial
before normalization for example but
let's think about the mechanisms of how
this is possible with neurofeedback we
know the medications change from a sort
of neutral metal levels in the brain and
these nutrient levels can be correlating
ions so how would people actually do the
same thing also particularly in the long
term turn on toxicity
well we're proposing well that was heavy
plasticity that actually is linked to
this relationship that I introduced the
beginning relation between power and
correlation between neurons sort of eg
power so what we see here is that with
increased amplitudes the phases are
aligned between neurons their activities
and we decrease power their phases are
not aligned now in fact during phase
alignment there's different
extensibility windows and this is
opportunity for the news to spike so
usually when the phase in the line so
when so what power is high then this
usually leads to increase some synaptic
what the potentiation which is sort of
made sort of made famous by this dictum
neurons that fire together wire together
and conversely if we decrease power as
we would in ADHD with the decreased its
power that would lead to some
incompatibility between the phases and
insight ability windows therefore they
would eat a long term depression because
the neurons will not fire at the same
time and therefore that will lead to
decrease of coupling between the neurons
and that's how then probably the thick
the rhythms are extinguished with time
in chemical operations and this would
this kind of model would work for any
type of and the frequency whether it's
gamma or beta and so on where we use and
know different abnormalities in the EEG
for example here there was a study in
ADHD I showed you that he says one of
the dominant patterns of humanity in
ADHD but there are also plenty of others
there is also the high Delta pattern
high beta pattern and even a high alpha
pattern so this shows that also there's
a heterogeneity even though clinically
there is a diagnosis of ADHD you're
physiologically there's a variety of
different things that can lead to
sustained kind of behaviors that are
indistinguishable in terms of clinical
diagnosis but when we look at the actual
brain correlates each of these groups is
unique but say or a subgroup which
actually then
makes a question of whether we also need
a sort of a personalized in your
feedback approach based on prior
screening of the EEG patterns and
therefore then the signing on then your
feedback button in your favorite
protocol feature in your feedback I
think he's moving in this direction so
this is a nice model in terms of hebbian
plasticity but actually is there any
evidence that there are some exceptions
of this rule and actually some recent
experiments of ours have shown this may
be the case also that there are some
exceptions in this role that not all
changes in the EEG current and direction
of your feedback training of the
protocol itself so we could say the
heavier model basically expects that if
you up try a particular rhythm then you
increase the power that power should
increase with time and should be then
promoted in the future in the resting
state with increased connectivity in the
brain and conversely that if you
decrease power that then these patterns
with these pitches we can decrease in
and inside us and therefore you have the
lower theater for example ADHD but we
found evidence for completely different
would say opposite phenomena which we we
saw in in Asians with post Matt's post
traumatic stress disorder now in this
case what we did was we also applied the
decrease of alpha during your feedback
and you can see here that during your
feed by alpha decreases commands in the
resting state but actually after one
session your feedback there's an
increase in alpha that was moving beyond
the initial value so this is not in line
with the heavy model where either the
resting state should be the same or
slower depending on how well patients
decrease their alpha in fact there's an
antique correlation between how low they
worked in you're using your feedback and
how much they offer pops up so this is
led to a lot of head-scratching and
thinking that what was going on but we
then afterwards
started to look at where
the PTSD patients lie on a normative
spectrum in terms of your initial alpha
values compared to a normative
population and what we found was in fact
that PTSD patients a much lower alpha
physically lower alpha attitude at
baseline and controls and if we then
look at what happens pretty post in your
feedback then we can see that there's an
increase of alpha in these PTC patients
and overall it looks like that increase
in alpha post your feedback actually
goes towards normal levels rather than
away from sin in fact there's a kind of
normalization DG going on despite the
fact that we're going away from the
direction of the north of spectrum in
terms of training the brain why is this
interesting well actually it's
interesting because there's also a
negative correlation with hyper arousal
which is one of the Cardinal symptoms of
PTSD therefore an increase in alpha as
you dissolve a rebound that we call
rebound actually predicts their decrease
in arousal so it has beneficial effects
for there will be so this is very
surprising finding that the brain would
sort of flip to the southern direction
and actually have a beneficial
therapeutic aspect to it and how can we
just explain any large or larger scheme
of things
well there are other work that shows
that in fact the brain self change
oscillations thermostat the key all the
time and this car is basically during
sleep weight cycle most prominently so
when you go to sleep usually p.m. your
power values of the EGR higher
especially in the theta and beats bands
and then as sleep occurs and there's a
slow wave oscillations that one of the
ears is a nice low wave oscillation is
downscale synapse is to lower coupling
values and therefore that's when you
wake up in the morning the a.m. values
are actually lower and power you can see
here significant a thetan be Tibet's so
the brain is constantly
oscillating between two extremes of high
coupling and lower coupling that is
probably seeking is critical reading
words then
for me to purchasing a memory I saw so
that's that's evidence for this kind of
mechanism occurring naturally and we
also know that with sleep deprivation
there are some pathological increases in
theta RS is shown by this study here by
myself after about 36 hours of sleep the
question if the powers is very high
abnormally high that post is normalized
it seems that these high theta values
may be also indications of pathological
kind of oscillatory activity and we know
that Jun sleep deprivation also
attentional functions are much weakened
there's a deficit in concentration
memory
so therefore overall the brain seems to
be able to do this what its own the
healthy brain it seems but maybe what
would happen in brain disorders is that
it's not able to do that and that once
you perturb the system with your
feedback for example the system is that
the guest is reactivated so how can we
visit messages so overall well here's a
summary plot summaries figure of where
all these kind of dimensions would lie
so if you start here the far right we
have the ADHD which is hyper coupled and
then with hebbian plasticity in the
direction of decreased decreased
connectivity we can train the brain down
towards this intermediate level of
synchronization in PTSD what would
happen is with this decreased of
decrease of amplitude protocol we would
go in the opposite direction right was a
low coupling in further than they
already are but at some point in the
brain would reach a bound
unlimited where it has turns on
sometimes dynamic answers we cannot go
even further because that is a hyper
excited for example the excitation
ignition balance would be more even more
greater so therefore the main mood and
shutting engage inhibitory mechanism
will bring the system back to the
intermediate equalization levels out of
its kind of sort of pathological tractor
that it was in at the beginning so
that's one model that is the main
therapeutic aspects of
is his demon work conversely we could
all such could also try to increase our
power directly in PTSD to go towards the
intermediate synchronization would have
been mechanisms that also seems to be a
potential benefit in fact some studies
have shown that increasing our commute
is deal directly with neurofeedback
improved symptoms and then lastly the
homeostatic aspect is that the brain
cumulates connectivity excuse ition with
time time awake when that sleep line
restores this back to the intermediate
civilization levels their signatures of
healthy brain function so overall this
model we proposed in in frontiers paper
in 2014 that we may explain some of
these have been affected so your
feedback as well as these paradoxical
effects in stasis potentially and before
future studies to determine whether you
know the model needs to be have some
more fine-tuning or also this is more
this one talks more mostly about local
connectivity so like power spectral
power but it may also be applicable to
the long distance connectivity in terms
of coherence and in this case also
particular hyper coupled or hyper hyper
coupled coherent patterns between
networks with also indicate departures
from optimality for example so many
things to still investigate we hope that
there will be some kind of framework
that we can understand and your people
neck how to apply to different disorders
and their heterogeneity in the future so
then that's the end of my talk thank you
very much thank you dr. Ross for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button once there's
many questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is how long do
neurofeedback treatment effects usually
last okay so essentially what I
described here was a mixture of
different different studies some studies
showing effects after just one session
on Aging our own studies that have
usually taken this approach to looking
mechanistic changes on the EEG but most
studies out there in terms of clinical
populations or long-term effects they
look at many many sessions on your
feedback after which treatments
discontinued so usually is up to 30 to
50 sessions on your feedback done on
daily basis or every episode and every
couple of days and what they find is
that what's up on ADHD the effects last
has been a recent meta-analysis show
that I compared to placebo or sham or
some groups your feedback effects are
actually conserve six months to 12 month
follow-up and ADHD also in epilepsy this
be some evidence showing that yes
ellipses eclipse' centers can be reduced
for many many years even with that
intervening training on your feedback so
it seems like the brain enters into new
configuration with training these new
coffee
music transition patterns of coupling
and therefore it's stable in that state
although not many studies have
investigated symptoms that are returned
that may be Kosovo and other diseases so
we don't know yet but most studies
indicated this is a beneficial aspect of
neurofeedback compared to for example
medication that for example medication
the symptoms you turn usually when when
medication is consumed and dr. Ross it
looks like we have time for one more
question what are the advantages and
disadvantages of neurofeedback
compared to other therapies such as
pharmaco therapy and non-invasive brain
stimulation
okay so overall I think you start with
the disadvantages I think essentially
your feedback takes a lot of time and
effort from patients which can sometimes
be fun but in many cases it can be quite
takes a lot of their time for example
each session master let's half an hour
one hour and then 50 of them so it's not
dedication from them and the effects are
very gradual so the gradual it can be
seen as also a positive or negative
because the effects are gradual just
like when you go to the gym you can
slide okay I don't feel well and I stop
here or I don't think this treatment is
going in the right direction so
therefore thanks I'm not massively
revolutionary all at once but they they
go towards something sometimes overall
the fact that there wasn't time so in
that case I think that gradualness
actually is more of an advantage because
in terms of safety I think that's when
your feedback really shines because
compared to other chickens like
electromagnetic stimulation or from a
therapy where we introduce external
fields the brain which we haven't been
tested for safety or even chemicals that
then the brain starts to depend on in
this case your feedback is completely
closed loop it doesn't involve any
external substance that enters into the
system and so this is learning
autonomously how to change itself I
think that's why I say its greatest
strengths so safety is one of the very
strengthening the other thing is that as
I mentioned before in terms long term
stability since the brain is doing the
work itself then usually once you
withdraw treatments the system is robust
afterwards and therefore there's no
sliding back of the symptoms disease
recurring which may not be the case in
other treatments where stimulation is
evolved because as we saw that brain can
become a static and their farm stasis is
a force to be reckoned with in the brain
in terms of treatment because the brain
is always adapting to the treatment so
once you introduce new things the brain
plaintiff gets used to them high bit
rates and is very difficult to live
without those things like medications
and so on so neurofeedback is is almost
a very different approach to treated in
brain swers I would like to once again
thank dr. Ross for his presence
I would also like to think Lab Rats for
making today's educational webcast
possible any questions that we're not
answered today will be answered via
email before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you'll receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye